do you want your iPhone battery to last
a very long time for example Angelica's
iPhone is still at 100 capacity after 8
months and mine is at 99
while some people in less than a year
have their battery all the way down to
85 percent While others a year after
getting it they're still at a hundred
well there are some tips to help you do
that either if you want your phone to
last a long time or if you want to
resell it for the maximum evaluator or
even pass it down to a family member or
friend well I'm going to share some
simple tips some more advanced tips and
some Extreme battery saving tips that
you've probably never heard about the
first tip is to make sure that optimized
battery charging is enabled in your
battery settings on your iPhone this
will make it so the phone will charge up
to 80 and stop until shortly before you
actually need it and that helps the
longevity the second tip is to make sure
you don't leave your phone out in direct
sun or in heat for example on your
dashboard in your car or even on a
CarMax safe Mount or vent mount where
you can have hot air blowing on the
phone heating it up because heat is one
thing that kills the battery and if that
sounds weird check this out Apple
themselves say that the ideal
temperature is between 62 to 72 and that
it is very important to avoid exposing
your device to higher than 95 degrees
Celsius or direct sunlight which can
permanently damage your battery capacity
and if you've ever had your iPhone lock
up saying that it is too high and needs
to cool down well that is very bad with
that if you use wireless charging use
Apple's macsafe charger because it
monitors temperature and it will
actually slow down or even stop charging
if your phone gets too hot and if you
use wireless power Banks use Apple's own
Max saved power bank because it can also
stop charging when it gets too hot or
when you're using apps that heat up to
save your battery whereas third-party
ones will keep charging your phone and
make it super hot and the last tip in
the simple category avoid letting your
battery die all the way if it's getting
low plug it in before it is dead because
that's one of the worst things that you
could do for a battery now for those of
you guys that want to get even more
serious in our Advanced category the
first thing you can do is switch from
using a fast charger all the time to
using a slow 5 watt charger overnight
which has an even charging rate and that
heats up your battery way less whereas
with the fast Chargers you will notice
that your phone will get hot and that is
because the fast Chargers will pump a
lot of wattage and heat into your
battery at first and then they will slow
down but overnight you don't really need
that now when you are fast charging take
off your case especially if it is thick
now if that sounds crazy Apple
themselves say to remove certain cases
during charging because it keeps in heat
damaging your battery with that avoid
having your battery be below 20 percent
or stay at a hundred percent for a long
time like keeping it plugged in all the
time we're charging when it doesn't need
to now if this sounds crazy most
electric cars will actually suggest not
letting it go below 20 percent and not
charging above 80 unless you're going on
a trip if you're going to use wireless
charging use something that has some
heat dissipation for example this stand
here has extra aluminum that draws out
heat or with that you can use slower
wireless charging that maxes out at 5
Watts or 7.5 or even use wireless
chargers that have cooling built in like
this one from ESR and any product I
suggest will be down in the description
with that if you're gaming or using
other applications that heat your phone
up don't have your phone plugged in at
the same time because you're just
stacking up a bunch of heat and then if
you're going to store your iPhone have
it around 50 percent because that is
when batteries are most stable now for
the extreme tips for those that want
your phone to last practically forever
and I'm not somebody that does it but
there are people that do the first tip
is to avoid wireless chargers altogether
because they make a lot of heat when
they're charging up your phone and that
is not necessary now the second tip is
if you're in an environment where it is
hot turn off your auto brightness
because with these newer phones that
their screens get very bright that just
Stacks up the amount of heat and it does
impact battery longevity and the same
thing with 5G if you're in a hot
environment you're using GPS if you can
shut that off that's going to keep your
phone running cooler and then if you are
gaming turn off auto brightness and set
it to about 50 percent because gaming
once again causes your phone to really
heat up next keep your phone own between
that twenty percent to eighty percent
don't let it die and don't charge it to
full now unlike some Android phones that
have built-in charging limitations your
iPhone does not have that so there are a
couple ways first don't just charge
overnight where your phone will hit a
hundred percent charger during the day
in the evening when you can kind of
monitor it and keep it in that range
that makes a massive impact for the long
term and for some people that get really
extreme they will actually uh stop their
phone from charging over 80 percent just
like you can on a Tesla now to do that
on an iPhone there are a couple of ways
first off you can buy a home kit
compatible wall outlet plug and then
create a home automation with it so that
when your phone reaches 80 percent that
outlet shuts off and you won't
overcharge your phone and the second way
is to download this app called chargie
which can actually pair up with an
inexpensive little charging adapter and
then you can easily control what your
charger levels and speeds are at along
with control based off of temperature
and using these tips from the simple
ones to the advanced or the absolutely
extreme you can have your iPhone be at a
hundred percent for a long time up to a
year or more and have an iPhone that
will last for five years with a battery
that is still really really good let me
know your thoughts down in the comment
section below none of these products are
sponsored but they are linked down in
the description click that Circle above
check out one of those videos right over
there this has been Max and I will see
you in the next one
[Music]
thank you